-Our first guests tonight
are the co-authors
of the number-one
"New York Times" best seller
"The President's Daughter,
which is out now.
Please welcome to the show
President Bill Clinton
and James Patterson.
[ Applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Thank you so much
for being here.
Hello, James. How are you?
Good to see you. Come on up.
♪♪♪♪
Welcome, gentlemen.
Here we are, big-time authors.
-Oh, cool. I get a couch now
-You get a whole couch.
-You might get to recline.
-We saw -- We were going t
have two chairs, but then,
we heard your writer insiste
that you have your own couch
-Can I lay out?
-Now, I want to start
by clarifying.
This is about --
Your previous book
was about a president
going missing.
This is about
a president's daughter
going missing,
different president.
-Different president.
-And out of office.
-Just out of office.
-Where do you get your ideas
a president out of office?
-Yeah, what a crazy idea.
-Well, this actually is a --
I think has
a very interesting premise
because what you find,
when you leave the White House
things change.
I mean, they don't play a song
when you walk in the room
anymore.
-Yeah.
-And you lose -- You keep
your Secret Service protection
for yourself and your spouse
but it's less.
And your children over 18
don't get it.
-Oh, I didn't realize
they lose it after 18.
-Yeah, and so this is a stor
about how the things you d
when you're president
that have consequences
other people don't like
can follow you
out of the office
ad fall on your children.
-Obviously, in your books,
these are very --
You know, they're thrillers.
A lot of extreme things happen
And yet we've seen since
your first book in 2018
even more extreme events
happen with real presidents.
Has it been harder
to write things that make people
say, "Wow, that's amazing"
-You know, back in the '60s,
Philip Roth --
Because we had Nixon
and Vietnam.
He said, "I can't compete.
I'll never write fiction again."
He then eventually
did write fiction again.
But that is an issue right now
-But if you look
at what happened
with the latest
cybersecurity stuff,
our book looks pretty realistic.
-Yeah.
-And this is also
very important, because we -
You're living in this worl
where these, you know,
people can be omnipresent
for all kinds of reasons
everywhere.
And what you do
when you're president
follows you afterwards.
So then you have to
figure out --
I mean, this is made
more interesting
by the alienation of the
president from his successor
and the uncertainty
that a former president ha
that his child
is going to be a top priority.
So you get a lot of interestin
cross-currents here.
-I have heard that you --
And I think when
we picture presidents reading,
we picture them
reading briefings
or maybe reading nonfiction.
But you did find time in offic
to read fiction.
Was that something
that helped as an escape
from the rigors of the job
or did you actually
find inspiration
in the pages of fiction
when you were in office?
-Oh, both.
I started in the early '80s.
I started reading thrillers,
mysteries, detective novels.
I was always fascinated by them.
And I found them --
the good ones -- really in
you know,
great character portraits.
-Yeah, a lot of the presidents
actually read
a lot of thrillers.
The Bushes both did,
President Clinton.
I don't know about President
Trump, but, you know, whatever
-He lived it. It was a thrill.
It was a thrill ride.
-And I read -- On occasion
I would read fiction books
because I thought they might
be an omen of what to do.
And I read "The Hot Zone,"
Richard Preston's
"The Hot Zone."
And it really accelerated
my efforts
to get the White House
to set up a special unit
on dealing with biological
and chemical outbreaks.
And especially
in the biological area,
both deliberate
biological warfare
and the possibility
of pandemics.
And we started working on this
in about 1998.
And that's -- We hatched
a lot of plans out.
We did a lot of
kind of war gaming,
I mean real efforts
with security people
all over America.
And we set up
the first stockpile.
So I've been waiting
for what happened with COVID
and we were --
Look, with SARS, with MERS
with all this stuff,
we were given plenty
of advanced warning
that something like this
could happen.
-Now James,
as an author who's aware
that you have presidents
in office who are reading book
and oftentimes
reading your books,
do you have a sense of the power
you might have to influenc
based on what you put
in your pages?
-I have no power.
-[ Laughter ]
-I'm here with Seth, I'm her
with President Clinton.
I'm the third wheel,
and that's the way it is
in life.
You know how it is for writers
You're a writer.
-Yes, I'm a writer
and oftentimes --
-Nobody listens to us.
-[ Laughter ]
-Nobody listens to him.
That's how he sold
400 million books.
-I didn't say
they don't read me.
They just don't listen to me
-When -- Do you guys ever have
arguments about a plot point
And then, is that a situation,
James, where a former presiden
maybe pulls rank on even someone
who's sold 400 million books
-We have never --
No, we've never had an argument.
I mean, we'll talk
about the different --
You know, one of the thing
I think that separates us --
Because a lot of the books
a lot of thrillers,
we make stuff up.
If I'm writing
with the president,
some of the stuff might be
a little over the top,
although nothing's
over the top these days.
But the president makes sure
that if it happens,
this is how it would happen,
and he's very strict about that.
And that's I think
what separates these books
-We don't have arguments.
What we really have is we have
interesting discussions,
because now that
I have done this twice,
basically,
as a student of a master,
what I have learned is,
we start with an outline.
We have a beginning. We thin
we know what the end is.
And we have an outline.
But then these people become
real as you write about them
-Yeah.
-And the scenes become vivid
And so the story lines begin
to take a little different turn.
And so one of the things
we would have to do --
Like in this last book,
we did it at the end --
We have to say, "Hey, we'r
gonna have two loose ends here
Let's figure out
how we're going to tie them up."
And then, you know --
-The endings
almost always change.
What I do -- and it's true
with the books we do together --
I like to pretend there's on
person sitting across from me,
and I don't want them to get u
until we finish the story.
And that's kind of
what we try to do
with "The President's Daughter."
-You --
I can only imagine
what it's like --
The way you write must be so
fast, James, based on output
Are you someone
that responded to the process?
I mean, I know
it's every two years,
but you have certainly
written other books.
-But it wasn't necessarily
every two years.
I don't know that we --
We missed each other.
That's why we got back together,
you know?
-We had a good time.
-"Let's do another one." Yeah.
-Hillary is writing a book
as well.
-We're not going to
talk about that.
Let her come here,
and she can sell her own books
-Yeah, I've heard
you're very competitive, yeah.
-And she's doing it
with Louise Penny,
who is a fabulous mystery writer
and a good friend of ours.
-She is.
-So there's a little bit
of gender
and as well as friendship
competition here.
And I've read the book.
It's a really good book.
It's going to be released --
-Unfortunately.
No, it's very good, very good.
-There's a lot of room
for everybody to succeed, James.
-No, there isn't.
There's very little room
at the number-one spot.
There's number one,
and, you know...
-Well, I mean, you know,
the important thing is
that you get your name
out there.
I think that's a very importan
thing for you to do.